Two things before we get started today.
One,
they're all weird
pronunciations in this one.
I'm looking them up when I can.
I have a laptop right here.
Sometimes it doesn't exist.
Sometimes they're just owned
the pronunciations available.
I'm doing my best,
but have a good.
I mean the comments if you want.
Second thing,
this video is brought
to you by squarespace.
Whether you need a domain,
website or online store,
make it with squarespace.
Check out squarespace.com
for a free trial.
Find the link below.
All right,
so for three years and eight months,
Pol Pot ruled over
Cambodia with an iron fist.
The legacy that he left his horrific
millions of families were torn apart.
Hundreds of thousands were
terribly tortured and one
point 7 million of his own
people will put to death.
So how did it end this way?
On this week's biographics,
we attempt to see.
Colin says,
as we delve into the life of Pol Pot,
the man who the world would
come to know was polled.
Part was born Sar on January the 25th,
19,
25 in the small village of praxis in
Cambodia is was a peasant family and from
an early age he found himself working
long hours in the rice fields.
The selloff Klan were better off than
many being landowners who worked that own
rice fields,
saw his father,
owns nine hashtags and would employ
local workers at harvest time.
His mother saw him was a
devoutly religious woman who
brought up her children as
Theravada Buddhists.
Saul was the second to
youngest of nine children,
however,
three of them died early
according to his brother and A.
Saul was a considerate,
kind and hard working child.
During the day,
he and his brothers
would work in the fields,
then play in the rivers and on
the outskirts of the jungle.
In the evening,
they would gather around and open,
fire and sing the teachings and
histories of a local religious leader.
For the vast majority
of Railroad Cambodians,
life revolved around the
rice fields in the village.
If you've ever traveled to beyond
the borders of their birthplace,
however,
wanted his sons to
experience more from life.
So when he was six,
Sar and his older brother was
sent to the Cambodian capital,
Phnom Penh loft had a cousin by the name
of me who was employed as a consort to
the king of Cambodia,
and the boys were sent to live with him,
no longer considered as peasants sergeant,
his brother well now among the privileged.
As such,
they were educated by the French.
Colonial rule is in a school where the
teaching was done in the French language,
saw studied French literature and history,
filling his head with the events of the
1789 French revolution and the reign of
terror that followed under the
orchestration of Maximilian Robespierre.
Former school names rather
than saw was there quiet,
introspective young man who
kept his thoughts to himself.
He was an average student at best
apparently being held back two years.
Most of his classmates were the
children of French officials or Catholic
Vietnamese.
Cambodia was officially a monarchy,
but the king,
he ruled in name only with the real
power lying with the French colonial
governments.
At this time,
the French were tied up in a bit of a
struggle to hold onto their power in
neighboring Vietnam bad.
The Communist army under Ho Ci Minh was
leading the struggle for independence,
the Vietnamese revolutionaries
that started to train
small groups of Cambodians
and infuse them with the desire for
independence from this European rule.
This was a movement that was
spreading throughout all of India,
China at this time,
at the age of 28,
so traveled with some friends on a
pilgrimage to the famous temples at Angkor
Wat.
This site was the rallying point
for Cambodian nationalistic pride.
The trip left a lasting impression
on the young men in 1970,
70 status.
If our people could build ankle wash,
they could do anything we must revive
on national soul and pride in order to
defend the nation bills the country
well then preserve it forever.
The trip mocks the awakening of saws,
political consciousness,
and his drawing for independence.
In 1947,
he passed the exams and gained entrance
into the Cecil was author secondary
college and Phnom Penh,
but the following year he failed the
entry exam into the upper classes and he
had to leave the school with his academic
career seemingly at a standstill.
He began to study carpentry.
Then in 1949,
do you want a scholarship to study at
an elite engineering school in Paris?
For the first few months,
he indulged in the excesses that
Parisians social life had to offer.
This thing's changed when he came into
contact with some fellow Cambodian,
so you had views that builds upon the
spark of nationalist pride that had been
ignited at Angkor Wat.
The group that began meeting at size
apartments and discussions can lead to the
formation of two groups,
one who advocated working peacefully
towards independence from the French and
the other who were in
favor of armed resistance.
From the very start saw
was in the latter camp.
He endures likeminded friends.
They pointed to other countries around
the world were armed overthrow was
working,
and they noticed they all
had one thing in common.
The rebels were all communists.
There was a vibrant communist movements
in Paris at the time and sirens.
Those of his group he
worked for armed rebellion,
began attending meetings,
saw again studying the
teachings of Karl Marx,
but found them difficult to understand.
However,
he readily cottoned onto the writings
of Joseph Stalin and became a lifelong
advocate of Stalinism with its
emphasis on rapid industrialization,
totalitarian governments,
and the cult of personality.
In 1951,
he joined the Communist Party and by
the time that he returned to Cambodia in
1953,
he had committed himself to the cause
of the Cambodian revolution once back on
Cambodians soil sir journey north to
join up with Cambodian forces who had
attached themselves to the Vietnamese
communists and that fight for independence
from the French.
He now lived in the jungle is
a perspective guerilla fighter,
but first he amped to
do an apprenticeship.
For the first few months,
his duties consisted of maintaining the
group's vegetable patch paydays recalled
most everyone that was Vietnamese that
were very few Cambodians for a long time,
there was nothing for me to do.
After awhile they let
me work in the kitchen,
but really the Cambodians
were there in name only.
Victory was achieved by Vietnamese
communists in 1953 following the French
disaster at the battle of DNB and food.
The French pulled out of not just Vietnam,
but Cambodia also.
However,
the new nationalists,
Cambodian government who has
had it not by a communist,
probably the King Norodom Sihanouk
still the top third of Cambodia,
was under the control of Viet Minh,
so Erin's other local communist soldier,
the Viet Minh to continue pushing south
until the entire country was communist.
But the leadership of
the Viet Minh resisted.
This surgeon's.
A truce was arranged with the king,
so now resend to Phnom Penh where he
continued to work for the political
undergrounds.
His Day job was as a school teacher
where he taught history by noise,
however,
he worked to establish contacts
with every strata of society,
from intellectuals to peasants in
order to garner support for the coming
communist revolution around this time,
so at the man who would become his
closest political associates and second in
command,
nuon chat,
chat later recalled that Sir had an
innate ability to charm people and bring
them into the party.
Having the ability to explain things in
a way that simple people were able to
understand,
so also met up with a
revolutionary students who he
had worked with in Paris by
the name of King Van Zach.
Together.
They worked on plans for the country's
first free and open political elections,
so I went to vans,
Zach's house for breakfast every morning
to work on their party's manifesto.
However,
that work did not come to fruition.
King Sihanouk because renounced his
throat and formed his own political party,
the satin chrome.
He threw his hat into the 1955 general
election and one becoming Cambodia's.
New Prime Minister Nuke
had achieved this victory,
though by throwing his political
rivals into prison for sub,
the Shaman action marks the end of any
hopes he may have had for a democratic
means to bring about
change in his country.
He confirmed his commitment to violence
overthrow wins through himself towards
working toward that goal in July of 1956.
So I married a fellow Communist Party
member by the name of q panare likes.
She had been educated in France and
was equally committed to the revolution
recourse.
They soon became the power couple of
the underground communist movements.
Life was increasingly dangerous for
the communists under the rule of CNN.
He had outlawed the Communist Party
and it's given them a new name,
the kind of of rouge,
the pace of imprisonments killings and
general Tara was stabbed top as the prime
minister to stamp out any and
all opposition to his rule.
The Communist Party secretary,
a close friend of so was taken to the
outskirts of Phnom Penh and killed his
during this climate of fear.
That's a accepted the
leadership of the Climber Rouge.
It was constantly followed by
the police who knew who he was,
but not his position in the party.
By 1960,
three things had gotten too hot for
Sarah in the capital city and d left to
dwell in the jungle in the north.
Yeah.
He was taken in by the Viet Minh who
had set up camps on the Vietnam Cambodia
border.
They were now focused on a new
enemy within their country.
That's of course the United
States from that Cambodian basis.
They would regularly traveling to
Vietnam to make lightening strikes before
retreating back over the border in
response to the American strawbs,
hundreds of thousands of tons of bombs
in north Cambodia and and attempts to
kill the Viet Minh and
the process they killed.
Over the course of the war,
nearly $150,000 Cambodians,
the American bombing,
have the effect of drawing more
and more people to the [inaudible].
Soon said no longer had to
rely only on the Viet Minh.
He now had his own gorilla camps stretched
out along the border and he himself,
he had transformed himself
in the mold of his hero,
Joseph Stalin.
He was the unquestioned party leader
and he now went by the name Paul Pot.
He lives apart from the rank and file of
his army and only allowed a select few
the privilege of having
an audience with him.
Paul believed that the lifeblood of his
revolutionary forces would come from the
peasantry,
but he also believed that they needed to
be molded so their soul allegiance was
to the party.
New recruits would undergo an intense
period of initiation where they would be
locked in a cell until they
were proven to be obedient.
Pole instituted as a rigid disciplinary
structure which included group meetings
where members have to confess their
weaknesses and seek forgiveness.
In 1970,
prime minister can newquist
overthrown by a military dictatorship.
He escape to the north and sought to
establish an alliance with this format
enemy,
the kind of bolstered by
the supporters of CNU.
The Canberra region
numbers rose by 64,000.
By the spring of 1964,
many of them went.
Now,
armed with Chinese supplied rifles,
pole vault saw me of gradually filtered
down from the border area and now
controlled two thirds of Cambodia.
By December of 1974 pole felt in a strong
enough position to make an assault on
the capital,
became a revision cycle,
Phnom Penh,
and began to close in
those you could flood.
The city is the streets became more zones.
Within five days,
the military government was
overpowered and the revolution was ifn.
April the 17th,
1975 was day zero and the
life of a new Cambodia,
Cambodia was now called Campo Chair and
it was under the control of it's stolen
and this leader Pol Pot.
Now,
just before we get into the really,
really dark part of this video,
Paul Potts reign of terror.
I do want to thank today's sponsor.
I know ads in the middle of these
videos are a little bit disruptive,
but these sorts of videos I think they're
important to make and they would be
impossible.
Our sponsors.
So I really do hope in exchange for this
long video about the life of Pol Pot.
You won't mind a quick word from the
fantastic squarespace if you've got an
important message to share,
you can do it with squarespace or maybe
you're like me and you need a place on
the web for people to find you,
or maybe you're starting a new business
and you need to set up a website for an
online presence or a store.
Well,
you should do all of that with
squarespace and with squarespace.
It all starts with a stunning template.
They really are super good looking,
or if you hate their beautiful templates,
I promise your won't.
You can start from
scratch and make it rain.
Squarespace.
Make it all super easy to make
something that looks amazing.
Furthermore,
you can easily move over an existing
domain and if you've hosted websites
anywhere else,
just move over to squarespace.
It's easy to do and then everything
after that point is just a lot easier.
With squarespace,
there's no patches,
there's no updates,
there's no tech crap that you
have to deal with all the time.
No one likes any of that.
Further,
squarespace does have 24 slash seven
support before making this out.
I went on and I tried it to see if I
could reach someone just randomly and
absolutely curd solid support.
It just works.
Look whatever you need a website for
whether it's for yourself or a business.
Squarespace is the place to do it.
Had to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com,
forward slash buyer graphics,
and you'll get 10 percent off your
first purchase of a website or domain.
Thanks again to
squarespace for sponsoring.
Check them out through the link below
and now let's get back to the misery that
is Pol Pot.
The people who have been on Penn,
they enthusiastically
welcomes the climate rouge,
but the smiles tend to alarm
at the ruthlessness of Poles.
Men,
they shot any military forces on site.
Then Paul ordered a massive
evacuation of the capital.
The reason given was that the Americans
were about to bomb Phnom Penh.
Guy Maria soldiers went into the city
forcing people out of hospitals in their
homes.
Many died in the streets
in the melee that followed.
The reality was that there was
no threat of an American outrage.
Pol Pot simply wanted to get the
people now so the way so that he could
concentrate on rebuilding his new society.
He told his aides that they must use
cutting edge violence in order to build a
socialist system from the ground up.
The 2 million people who were forced out
of Phnom Penh has a pass through these
checkpoints on the outskirts of the city
that they were assigned to districts
for reeducation as field laborers,
the policy of equality with
strictly enforced with any
possessions that set city
folk apart from the peasantry
being taken off them,
Kangaroos,
soldiers went through the now deserted
capital and destroyed any of the
trappings of modern civilization
that they could find.
Any people who were found to be hiding
were taken into the street and shot under
Pol Pot regime.
Communist to quality meant that
everyone wants to be a peasant.
As a result of all of the modern
advances of the last 100 years.
They were rejected and even though former
city dwellers and peasants were now
working in the field side by side,
that kind of rear driver see us held a
special hatred for the form of urbanites
who are considered to be capitalists.
They were given only half of the
food rations of the peasants.
The equality policy included children to
live with [inaudible] teachers from the
age of seven onwards.
Private thoughts and feelings were
considered to be evil with uniformity,
the only acceptable way of life the
state who would choose which people got
married and anyone who was suspected
of falling in love outside of this
arrangements have beaten
to death and public.
The regime outlawed any form of
entertainment including sports with former
sports fields and basketball courts
being planted as rice fields.
The feeling of terror that had been
generated reached into the Asher lawns of
power with members of Paul's governments.
Iga.
It's approved that they too were
peasants and they worked in the fields.
As a result,
there was no real governance.
Poland's did use it,
a rice harvesting quota on the people,
which was three tons of
unhosted rice per hectare,
but less than a third of this
was actually being produced.
Meanwhile,
the people were suffering physically.
Disease was rife,
and millions suffered from malnutrition.
Hundreds of people were
dying every single day.
Paul blames the lack of success of his
great vision on infiltrators and enemies
of the party.
He devised a great purge to weed out
those nonconformists estate secrets.
Interrogations and do is set it
up so you in prison and torture.
Those were expected of being traitors.
The families of those arrested would
also be taken to the prison and tortured.
If a child was too young
to be interrogated,
it would be taken away and
simply killed immediately.
Any adults that you survived,
that torture were taken out to the
killing fields and beaten to death of the
14,000 prisoners you pass through the
gates of the main interrogation center in
Phnom Penh.
Only seven survived.
Many of those killed were loyal supporters
who were falsely accused of treason.
Paul Potts had succeeded in imposing his
ruthless iron fisted control within the
borders of Cambodia,
but there was a new threat to
his regime just over the border.
The Vietnamese is having seen off the
Americans now turn their attention on
Cambodia.
A border dispute threatened to bring
these two countries to war as the tensions
were rising.
Paulo did his latest purge
right on the border zone.
He suspected his defensive forces in that
area of colluding with the Vietnamese
after being viciously interrogated
more than 100,000 soldiers and party
officials along with their wives and that
children were executed as a result of
this wholesale massacre
of his own defense forces.
Paul left is eastern border with Vietnam
open to invasion and that invasion came
on Christmas Day.
Nineteen 78,
taking just 13 days for the
capital of Phnom Penh to fall.
Pol Pot managed to slip away
and escape into the jungle,
but at least his three and a half
year reign of terror was over.
In total it'd cost the lives
of nearly 2 million people.
The caiman ridge may have been over,
but the party persisted for nearly 20
years at retina and continued to wage
guerrilla warfare from its jungle basis.
Ballpark,
set up a base near the Thai border and
rebuilt his military force with the aid
of the Chinese and Thai governments.
Meanwhile,
the Vietnamese that installed a new
government made up of kind of rear
supporters who had escaped polls pageants
from his base in the
northern part of the country.
Paul gave occasional interviews
to reporters in which he
would invariably accuse
those who opposed him of being traitors.
In 1985,
it was announced that he was retiring
from the leadership of the kind of rouge.
Shortly thereafter,
the enemy's clamps down on the climate
region moving into their strongholds and
decimating that basis.
Paul managed to escape into Thailand's
where he remained for the next few years.
In 1988,
he went to China to undergo
treatment for cancer.
The enemy's withdrew from Cambodia.
In 1988 prompting polls
or a from Thailand.
For the next eight years,
the Caiman Rouge ran guerrilla
operations against government forces.
In 1996,
the government began engaging in peace
negotiations with individual kind of
leaders,
leading many of them to effect
away from the organization.
Meanwhile,
Paul had suffered a stroke and was
paralyzed on the left side of his body,
but this didn't stop him from
handing out death sentences.
When he heard that his
longtime righthand man,
I'm was negotiating with the government,
the audit,
his arrest and execution around this
time that they've been members of Paul's
family were also killed.
Though it is unclear whether
he ordered those killings.
On June the 19th,
19,
97 pole was arrested by the head of
the military who had had enough of his
murderous ways.
A show trial was conducted
for the ordering of the
execution of transcendence.
Pole was confined to house
arrest for the rest of his life
and it's finally,
as Paul had become an avid listener to
the voice of America radio show on the
night of April the 17th,
1998.
He was surprised to hear that the
[inaudible] should agree to handover to an
international tribunal for
crimes against humanity.
Later that night,
he died in bed.
Paul Paul's body was requested by the
Cambodian government for inspection,
however,
he was cremated and his followers before
the government could get their hands on
it.
This is that.
Be Able to speculate that he actually
committed suicide rather than being handed
over to the court.
As a result,
neither he nor anyone else has ever
faced justice for the horror of Cambodian
killing fields.
So I'm not going to ask
whether you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it informative
and maybe brought this part of history to
life for you.
If you did like it,
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell.
If you do want to hear about all videos,
just sitting subscribed doesn't
do what it used to on Youtube,
so do hit that,
that as well as you do.
Find out when we put out new videos and
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now,
why not check out some of the bio's link?
Do on the screen now and as always,
thank you for watching.